[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream Q&A section we are
here staring down the barrel of martial
law ready to answer your super chat
questions so without further ado shall
we get to it let's do it all right okay
our friend Holly math nerd asks my dear
friend in Michigan which is a swing
state is a classical liberal and has a
dilemma she rightly sees Trump as a
psycho and DNC as corrupt with neither
candidate fit for office who does game
theory suggest she vote for it's a very
good question yeah but I think the
answer is obvious frankly Wow yep
it's yang McRaven or McRaven yang I
don't know which one it's gonna be but
it's definitely that ticket because you
know what there's one thing we have to
do we have to defeat Trump Biden in 2020
we have to defeat Trump Biden there's no
question about it we should have
defeated Trump Clinton in 2016 this time
we have to defeat Trump Biden so what
does an individual do well honestly I
think it is up to those of us who have a
certain amount of reach in the world to
derail this runaway train before it
reaches the station that it's going to
go barreling through or whatever the
proper way to end that analogy is how
will derail not simply leave one of the
two presumptive next presidents in power
no I'm dead serious
I think the announcement by our two
major parties that they are not serious
about leading in an era where we face
things as scary as SARS Cove 2 and the
breakdown of law and order over there's
just no question this has to end we
cannot play the the duallies game
anymore it has to end
I guess my point would be look the only
reason we didn't end it before everybody
knows it's broken
the only reason we didn't end it before
is because it would be impossible to end
it but impossible things are now
happening every day so this is the era
of the impossible it is time that we
challenge this dynamic because we ain't
gonna survive if we let it run its
course all right I'll let the dog finish
up your thought for you it's like I
wonder if you can get her to be quiet
thank you sweetie okay Heather and Brett
thank you the major media appears to be
ignoring an Tifa there is so this is so
underreported that convincing people of
its veracity is almost impossible advice
also is Benjamin Boyce a trustworthy
journalist it seemed that second thing
seems a little bit of a non sequitur
although he's obviously spoken somewhat
to anti [ __ ] yeah yeah Benjamin Boyce is
a top-notch guy and a trustworthy human
being I don't know the he'd call himself
a journalist I don't know what
journalist means in this era given what
has happened to journalists but I
certainly trust Benjamin I don't trust
anybody
I don't trust anybody's judgement
completely but I trust his integrity
yeah no I would absolutely agree with
that I'm not sure I would have I
wouldn't have thought to use the word
journalist to describe him and if he
does then I should rethink that because
I trust him to choose his his titles
carefully but certainly the work that he
has done that I'm most familiar with
which is on Evergreen has been
extraordinary and detailed and both
accurate and precise yeah
with respect to the first part of the
question the problem with the aunty Fay
issue is a unless you've tangled with
them directly you don't necessarily know
what it is and also the fact that
they've labeled themselves in the style
of the Patriot Act it's hard to attack
the Patriot Act because you don't seem
like a patriot it's hard to attack and
Tifa because it sounds like you might be
favoring fascism now of course neither
of those things are true but there are
many examples of this we should we
should devote more time at some point to
talking about
things that come with these labels like
pro-life and sex positive as well yeah
yeah what I would say is I think it is
well worth having people consider the
game theory in other words and I tweeted
about this today and I thought I thought
I got it which was if you have you know
all of these people you're looking down
on this protest and they're trying to
figure out how to negotiate with each
other and you know anybody in the group
can sabotage it anybody who prefers
violence can sabotage it by setting off
a firecracker or throwing something at
any moment you can't get anywhere and so
once you've talked to the anarchists and
you know that they don't want peace
because they don't believe you could fix
the system and then you understand that
they are interspersed in these crowds
that they're spray paint even if the
crowd doesn't believe that all cops are
bastards the fact that all the walls
seem to reflect the fact that the crowds
I think all cops are bastards that can't
be positive so anyway if you have a
journalist that you know sit them down
and have them think this through the
disproportionate influence of the the
anarchists is going to make peace
impossible and what happens when peace
is impossible well we saw over the 15
minute break after our initial part of
this live stream that we have a massive
military force being deployed and
they've been issued bayonets
so that's where we are bayonets yeah
let's not let the anti if I push us into
battle to trench warfare well into
bayonets let's say one does not want to
be pushed into bayonets I'm not sure
what this next question means so much or
it's complete isn't this part of trumps
second amendment Trump second amendment
being in quotes
especially where government surrenders
to writers rioters and looters so maybe
isn't this this thing that we're living
maybe that's what the question is asking
are you can you make
the intention here you know I watched
the speech and was left very puzzled by
numerous parts of it including that line
and I think it was very clearly I mean
I'm not even sure it was a coherent
thought I think the idea was it was a
wink at that fraction of the electorate
that sees the second amendment as the
core of the Constitution and I will so
let me just say the next question is
also about the second amendments maybe
we can we can talk about a little bit
yeah
addressed to me Heather the Second
Amendment is as profound a right as the
first some mayors and governors would
have it otherwise a shot across their
bow so I absolutely the second is as
profound as the first you know the whole
Bill of Rights are all quite profound
with the possible exception of the third
which just seems less relevant now but
so yeah I agree with you I just don't
know why it bore particular mention
there but the second part of this second
question that we're addressing now with
regard to the second amendment may may
be part of it that this was a wink
perhaps not so much to would-be
enthusiasts of a civil war but a poke
rather than a wink at the mayors and
governors who are publicly and famously
opposed to the way the Second Amendment
is being realized in America today a
couple things one I don't think the
Second Amendment is as profound as the
first and I don't think it can be
because the first can be quite
unambiguous and the fact is you don't
have a right to a nuclear weapon
therefore your right to bear arms is
inherently limited and where we draw
those lines is inherently less
interesting than whether we let you say
whatever it is that you feel you should
say well and the first also and I won't
remember all of them but it has you know
it has this remarkable it's just this
beautifully constructed sentence or a
few sentences I can't remember but
beautifully constructed thing which
basically goes from the most personal to
the most public with regard to the
freedom of
of you know thoughts thoughts that you
may have in the which doesn't go in the
opposite direction I can't remember it
now but it covers all range of you know
from what you believe - what'd you say -
what you proclaim and where you can say
it and how you can how you can exchange
the ideas and so you know really does
cover all of these bases so it's you
know it is it's a larger scope of of of
amendments than the second yeah now the
second is potentially very important and
I should say this is one of the places
that I run afoul of our liberal friends
is that I don't think it's a slam-dunk
that the Second Amendment is just an
anachronism I think it it is about
tyranny and there's a question about how
relevant the arms that citizens can have
are to full-scale governmental tyranny
are there actually art there are there
people arguing that everything about the
Second Amendment is an anachronism like
I actually don't don't know that to be a
position that's live now well it's not
the craziest position in the world I
mean the fact is you know muzzleloading
muskets or you know just not a good
model so the people who wrote the
amendment didn't really understand what
what the amendment would end up covering
yep but on the other hand yeah I mean it
is phrased in a way that it makes it a
curious statement right the the invoking
of the concept of a militia being the
justification for the right to bear arms
not being infringed is a head-scratcher
at some level so anyway there's a lot of
ink spilled on this of course but the
basic point is I think it has to do with
tyranny and I think it's still relevant
and that means that at some level we are
paying a huge price annually for this
hedge against tyranny which presumably
hasn't reared its ugly head in recent
memory because you know the firearms
that would be relevant to it haven't
been utilized so anyway we're you know
it's a hedge against something that
might happen on the other hand at the
moment that we have soldiers being
now deployed with bayonets to go keep
peace amongst Americans on American soil
I don't know what to think
and you know the problem is to the
extent that your personal weapons might
be used to fend off tyranny look at what
you're up against you're up against the
American military you know so I mean and
hopefully that's not where we are and
you know the thing I tweeted just before
we went online here was that in light of
the bayonets this was a good moment for
patriotic Americans to remind each other
that following immoral orders is immoral
and I really think that's that's the
central concept and I must say what I
expect to happen if the order for
tyranny comes down from the top I expect
the military to reject it right that's
what you should do that's what you must
do and I expect you to do it if that
doesn't happen what happens with you
know I think I'm probably happy that the
population is well enough armed that it
simply will not roll over in the face of
tyranny and I think there are great many
very decent Americans who have weapons
and will protect people who don't have
them if it comes to it so I find it odd
that we are now talking about that in
real time as if it might be just around
the corner but you know in light of
bayonets
how much farther down the road are we
with bayonets today than we were
yesterday at the threat of martial law
yeah well we saw we saw some evidence of
this three years ago when Everton was
blowing up and there was a moment before
we actually fled the state and our home
with our children because the threat of
violence was so real and a few among our
friends only one of whom I knew in
advance had a concealed carry permit
revealed themselves to to have arms and
to be prepared to stand at the top of
our driveway and defend us and we you
know we thank them and for their for
their courage and for their
friendship and said we didn't need that
but it was it was a surprise and I felt
safer for it yeah actually now I always
feel the need to add when you mentioned
this that we left the state because we
had children and because members of our
family told us that effectively they
didn't see us as having a choice I would
not have left and there's a part of me
that regrets leaving but yes it was the
right choice to do it all right there is
there is much more to be said about the
second amendment but maybe we'll leave
that for there for now
let's see so are we on the other side of
the pandemic or just getting of the
second wave that will come crashing down
harder than before I see no evidence
that we're on the other side of the
pandemic yeah it's not talking about it
very much we're not talking about it
there's some bad information floating
around from Italy about what's that I
don't know this a report came out I'm
not convinced something wasn't lost in
translation that suggested that the the
virus was losing potency when in fact
the whole thing was confounded by the
fact that we're getting better at
figuring out how to fight it we're doing
better at not spreading it and so these
things look it looks like it's becoming
less dangerous but that doesn't have
anything to say about whether the virus
is becoming less dangerous and what's
more I mean potency is also I think
maybe I'm wrong I think not a term of
medical art like virulence is a term of
art but with this Pope like what does
potency me lethality was the implication
but the question is why is it less
lethal and even even let's say the virus
that is being seen in Italy there's some
argument to be made that it is less
lethal that doesn't have anything to say
about the viruses that departed from the
tree and left that branch the
phylogenetic tree right and so you know
at some level the virus isn't the virus
the virus is innumerable
lineages separate from each other and
the fact that one of them may be showing
some sign of something is certainly
interesting if it is and I'm
convinced that this Italian report tells
us that it was but even if it did it
doesn't say anything about some virus
that's disconnected from it in some
other part of the world so yes I think
we are about to see another wave by
virtue of the fact that we're opening
back up and as we've said many times
there's an argument to be made for
opening back up there really isn't an
argument to be made for not doing so in
an extremely careful and enlightened way
you can probably afford to open the
outdoor spaces back up you should
probably wear masks when you go there
but enjoy them make your vitamin D while
you can because winter will be back I
promise and you know like that but
opening back up means enclosed spaces
where the thing is transmitted and a
very heightened level of enlightened
caution is the key way to allow opening
back up not to produce a major new wave
though it is effectively sure to cause
some bump yeah if history serves if this
virus is like other viruses there will
at least be a second and perhaps a third
wave maybe within a couple weeks and
maybe in the fall in the northern fall
and maybe again in next spring
sure again the vitamin D link is so
important here I have now begun to see
the wider conversation take up the point
that we've been making about outdoors
being safe so Pamela pesky had an
article in New York Times couple days
ago that discussed the relative safety
of outdoors and then there was another
article who was a just I just saw it
today but anyway a couple a couple major
publications have now begun discussing
the fact that outdoors for whatever
reason appears to be almost safe and
that that has implications on what we
ought to do one of them being in light
of the fact that vitamin D seems to be
both preventive in terms of getting you
not to catch the disease and
it's valuable in terms of not getting
very sick from it
making your vitamin D now while the sun
is shining here in the northern
hemisphere makes so much sense so if you
do that now then when it comes back
there'll be less illness yep next
question Heather Bret agreed with you on
white nationalists
the notion that is constantly spoken it
is utter nonsense most times is the
white nationalist or supremacist or
whatever show up in public events thank
you yeah you know I think if my cartoon
idea of what white nationalists look
like is right and I don't know if it is
they like antifa
tend to show up and want to be
identified as such white nationalists
don't want to be cryptic now maybe I'm
wrong if if they were trying to incite
violence in the streets without it being
clear that it was them such that there
was a reason then it was explicable why
they then showed up then perhaps we
wouldn't be seeing evidence of them now
but in in general you know they they
show up and they're proud of it and
they're proud of who they are and and
tea for the same way you can't you can't
tell who's who where the DFO because
they're masked even when it's not
pandemic times but let me say this
you've got your dyed-in-the-wool white
nationalists who are committed that this
is the right answer and there will be no
reasoning with them and then you've got
a lot of people who are flirting with
the idea because superficially it sounds
like the solution to some problem we do
have a race problem hey this would be
one way to solve it right well I don't
think so and I would like those of you
who are flirting with this idea to think
very very carefully of what it is that
you are actually proposing and what it
would mean and also to consider the
possibility that we are not that far
from a society that works that is
multiracial and that were we to reach it
you would be so much the better for it
the the burden of suspect
other people on the basis of their
lineage is so great that really guys
consider just giving it up alright I
want you throw your lot in with the rest
of us let's fix this and let's all
benefit from having done so it's by far
the easiest route and the most honorable
route I see no other path say that to
get utility from their religious
circuitry you want a religion to install
in the heads of a population you're
taking to a habitable island can you
each give two pillars you would want in
such a religion yeah I mean this is
unfortunately the hard part of this is
narrowing it to two pillars and you know
it's obviously a question of accepting
the premise of yeah having a hard time
I'm having a hard time with the promise
of putting putting something that is to
be taken on faith into people's heads
and I'm not saying that it's not an
interesting question but I think I have
literally not spent any time on this on
this premise I would I would like to
perhaps come back to this good time but
there you go I will say I'd like to just
fix the premise and say if we replace
religion with something that is doing
the job of religion in your hypothetical
scenario here then the question is what
pillars would be important to include
and there are many in fact we have a a
Chanukah tradition where each night we
go through one of what we think are
foundational principles that are worthy
of revisiting annually so any way we
could pick any of those but two of them
would be don't game honorable systems
that would be one and that if you're
proposing something new that might have
a downside it has to be sustainable and
reversible that is to say if it turns
out it was some kind of a big error you
have to be able to undo it
before you are allowed to do it in the
first place very good yeah and I guess
just to pick two others from that list
that will be known to the listeners the
golden rule is of course on there do
unto others as you would have them do
unto you
and the precautionary principle which is
related to one of the ones that you just
said yep okay how many potential COBIT
19 deaths will result from these
protests and riots so I think you
addressed that ish at the end of the I
would say extreme among the many many
reasons not to engage in looting
diluting is taking place indoors and it
is much safer to be outdoors so add it
to your list of reasons if you were on
the fence about looting you have about a
thousand independently sufficient
reasons this is on the list somewhere
yeah good do you have any plans to
divide your live streams into a series
of smaller videos edited by topic like
Gerry clips yes we should it is a large
task and we have not figured out yet how
to get it done yes
were we able to push a button and have
it happen this is something we would
have done a long time ago it's
definitely on the list from a Darwinian
perspective what is the value of
conscience conscience life conscience
like a moral responsibility yeah so I'm
gonna just quickly say you know Brett
actually wrote a paper on the evolution
of morality along with our friend David
lotta you and here co-authors on the
paper
yeah and it's terrific and if I think it
I will put that in the link yeah the
basic in the in the description of this
video the basic answer is that there's
going to be something on a temporal
scale or a spatial scale that is
valuable which is not recovered I narrow
self-interest and so conscience is
basically a corrective lens that causes
an increase in well-being over time or
space so any way you can imagine
you can you can try all sorts of
examples where there's something that if
you did it would result in an immediate
benefit to you but it would make you
feel guilty so you don't do it and then
if you think about what the guilt is a
proxy for it actually maintains a kind
of good that will be destroyed if you
were to engage in that action okay
echo asks can you both give your
evolutionary perspective on beauty is
the beauty we perceive in landscapes and
objects related to how well they match
our historical niches B G good habitat
food preferences tool efficiency it's a
it's a beautiful question yeah in fact
and I think every one of the ways that
you can assess whether or not something
has evolutionary efficacy is how
universal it is across across cultures
and there is a sense of aesthetic there
is you know a philosophy of us a
philosophy of aesthetics and a sense of
aesthetic in all of the major religions
and I believe in pretty much every
culture where it's been looked at
although anthropologists haven't been
focused on that as much so it's hard to
know what its absence might mean in
places where it hasn't been noted so yes
in part what we find beautiful has has
been linked with those places like you
say here you know good habitat food
preferences I'm less sure about tool
efficiency but probably actually with
regard to for instance this this
beautiful knife that you you have behind
you here that our friend Dave made for
you you know why why do we find the cut
of a particular blade beautiful as
opposed to another and you know that
without without being you know myself
say just you know a knife maker or
someone who is used knives for anything
but pretty banal tasks I still know a
beautiful blade when I see it and my
suspicion is that is pretty well mapped
on to those blades that will be
efficient and effective for the jobs
that they are best designed for
yeah I would say it's a proxy for
goodness it doesn't mean it's perfect
proxy but it's a proxy for goodness and
there's a positive feedback in it
because to the extent let's say you have
some natural preference for some kind of
beauty that is correlated to some kind
of goodness let's say it isn't in a tool
or something like that your mind has
some sense of symmetry and balance or
something that causes one blade to look
good well then that beautiful blade that
then you use and it's very effective
reinforces the part of the proxy that's
accurate and so you can actually imagine
that the proxy would get refined through
use and you know you you would become
more sensitive to what was actually a
beautiful blade and what was kind of a
bit bit of a counterfeit or something
like that so anyway you would it would
be a refine able proxy for goodness over
time ya know and the fact I mean just
just to pick up on blades you know the
fact that a knife with a broken tip or
with chips out of it notches in the
blade everyone finds that less beautiful
it is less effective yep mm-hmm
great for Zack and a little bro hate to
break it to you guys but you have cool
parents I strongly suggest you continue
to be receptive to their input and
openly keep it real with them when you
disagree you hear that ma'am okay yeah
yeah yeah no they're they're off it
wasn't cheap for me to put that comment
and hit the list so listen up know our
we've got two teenage boys and they're
both completely fabulous they're keepers
yeah yeah yes you can't have them let's
see why is it automatically assumed that
if a white policeman abuses or harms a
black suspect that that is an instance
of racism isn't that one tribal and to a
surrendered to a false definition of
racism yeah and I think I mean this I
presume that this came in before we
actually talked about this in the first
live stream it's it it is an error it's
a it's a fallacy and it is certainly
more likely that then if the races were
reversed that people would think it was
racism or that it was because of what
history has looked like
it isn't apparently racism at all that
you know what I say in my initial 14
points you know some cops are racist
thugs well simply by statistical
inference more cops than that are simply
thugs that you add racist to the mix and
it's a smaller group and therefore less
likely so there are more there are more
bad cops out there who are just thuggish
than are also racist and thuggish and of
course the vast majority of them are
neither you know it's funny how often
Rodney King's famous line comes to mind
can't we all just get along
I must say I found that line haunting
and endearing when he first said it and
it has stuck with me and at some level
you know I I get that we have a race
problem that's interfacing badly with
police but for God's sake him people can
we just get over this seriously it's not
helping us it's not what do you think
about Mike Pence you see the real you
see the religious lunatic people say he
has boy you got something I'm a knight I
haven't thought a lot about Mike Pence
honestly like I'll just I'll just answer
off-the-cuff I haven't given him a lot
of thought he was easy to mock for him
being you know almost bible-thumping II
I don't want him to be president but I'm
not sure that he's a complete lunatic
like people say he is I don't really I
don't have a bead on him really well I
don't want him to be president for
Policy reasons it's possible that I
don't know I let's put it this way I'm
damned if I do and damned if I don't
hear because in some sense I don't know
anything about him that yes I find him
curious and some of the things he
apparently believes seem strange to me
but in archaic right I mean he's like a
pre-modern do
at some level whose in one of the
highest offices in the land yeah and
there's something there's something
paradoxical about that you know I'm not
thrown by Amish people in their
pre-modern hope but they're not
vice-president right that's the thing is
it's it's so I guess my point then is if
it's the context that makes Mike Pence a
troubling phenomenon I'm not sure I
necessarily want to hold him responsible
for that
I guess I'd also say that you know we've
we've known I don't know if I've known
any Amish people but we know some
Mennonites and I would actually be
pleased to have some you know at least
one Mennonite in particular I'm thinking
of and you know I'm thinking of be in a
position of power and it is a because we
know him so very well and it is it is a
position that is so carefully
thought-out and not based on received
wisdom and the at least the cartoon
thing in my head about Mike Pence is the
DS just sort of receive I'm a Christian
and I take what's written in this book
as that's literally the Word of God and
that is a that is a received wisdom sort
of authoritarian take that I don't trust
in a leader yeah yep
thank you for also sharing the data
about the reality of these police
killings of black folks greater chance
of being struck by lightning literally
love you both I don't know exactly what
the greater chance of being struck by
lightning refers to that is you're more
but a black person is more likely to be
struck by lightning than to be killed by
a cop it is what I think that means I
don't know if it's true it seems like it
could well be I don't think there's a
question there though right thanks for
the honest commentary from Texas you're
welcome
consider that rioting makes everyone
feel the pain of the oppressed and
ignored have you considered the looting
reflects racial financial inequality
yeah whenever Green was melting down we
repeatedly made the point that the
problem with the movement was that
instead of ending racism it appeared to
be interested in turning the tables so
there is I think a deep-seated
primordial instinct to turn the tables
and to simply destroy but what I would
say is look the great leaders who have
gotten us past major in justices have
understood that they need discipline
that they need to be they need to resist
base impulses in order to to reveal the
hypocrisy of the system they're
challenging and this protest is so
thoroughly failing to do that that I
think for all of us who frankly I you
know I am frustrated I do think we are
falling down on our obligation I don't
think we're falling down on our
obligation for the same reason that many
of the protesters feel that we are I
think there's a diminishing returns
problem where the the things that
continue to cause racial injustice have
become subtle and because they are
subtle there's a frustration about not
being able to name them and so there's a
temptation to point to things that
aren't exactly right and and all of that
but if you're going to force change then
you need to think about perceptions and
you know Gandhi understood this Martin
Luther King understood this and you know
the the lack of anybody to speak for the
movement and the lack of discipline of
the protesters is so thoroughly
counterproductive that there's almost
nothing else that needs to be said right
we can talk about what it actually is
but the point is you're losing people
who were listening that's not a good
idea
if I feel that white people are now
under threat of racial violence does
that make me a white nationalist oh no
no of course not
okay I think I can't imagine why it
would I have the problem with white
nationalism is that it seeks a white
state that's the whole idea and that's
it's an awesome we are its unpatriotic
it son decent and no the recognition
that white people are being singled out
now is just a fact and it doesn't make
it Universal and it doesn't mean that it
is the equivalent of what black people
or Indians have suffered but but you
know it is a fact why people are being
singled out and none of us are quite
sure what to do about 35 minutes okay
let's get to more in here and then we'll
switch the questions in the next live
stream hi thank you I'm seeing a lot of
there was only one race there is no
racism gene it has learned posts from an
evolutionary perspective why do some
believe this and virtue signal it about
virtue signal about it on Facebook and
Instagram when it is false yeah I think
unfortunately my grandfather used to
frequently argue that education was the
solution to all of our problems and he
and I used to fight about this because
he wasn't right there are lots of things
that you could understand and it doesn't
fix them but there is a sense in which
understanding them gives you a great
advantage in figuring out how to address
them I mean game theory is something I
invoke all the time for this reason once
you see the very simple dynamics that
cause something that should work not to
work you can begin to say well what
would have to be different in order to
make the thing function so I think the
problem is lots of people have been
failed by an educational system that's
so preposterous and so thoroughly fails
to put in front of you the things you
need to know that they are just left
adrift figuring out how to think about
problems and it would be very nice
if racism had no evolutionary basis I
would love that to be the case anything
so much simpler the question really
though is how could it possibly be true
how could it possibly be true the fact
is a lineage of people that is capable
of ganging up on other lineages of
people has an advantage that a lineage
that can't figure out who it's related
to doesn't so it can't possibly be true
what is true is that racial allegiance
is not the only basis on which we can
move forward and those of us who have
figured out how to put it aside have
actually discovered that there's a
tremendous amount of value to be
unlocked in doing so so we don't need it
to be true that there is no evolutionary
basis for racism in order for us to get
past it many of us have and pretending
that it's not true is going to make it
harder to move forward makes it
impossible because it means that your
your your system is stacked on a
foundation that's partially crumbling
mythological okay so anyway I I don't
know I think people are basically
confused about the nature of what they
want to be true and what relationship it
has to what is true and you know there
are many marvelous quotes from the
history of science from some of our best
minds there's one in particular from
Medawar in which he says something to
the effect of it's amazing how little
effect what you want to be true has on
what is true yeah and it's that you know
it's the reason that the concept that
the naturalistic fallacy has been
formalized the way it has which is to
say the idea that what is true is what
ought to be true is false it's it's
simply it's a it's a false equivalence
and many people imagine it's some sort
of a mystical thing that once you
understand what is and you speak it then
it will become the thing that ought to
be true for all time and it's the thing
that you want to be true and know like
you know what one thing that we one of
the things that we speak to all the time
is we understand if we can understand
the evolutionary underpinnings of what
we are and why we do the things that we
do we will be much better equipped to
actually move away from those
evolutionary underpinnings the the only
thing our genes one of us have to make
more of themselves in the future that's
not interesting we can do better we can
do a lot better you can do a lot better
the other problem though is there's the
sense and you know I don't think
scientists are doing us any favors the
fact that the virology community has
this fiction it likes which is the
laboratory hypothesis couldn't possibly
rewrite that thing is effectively it
trying to take a fiction and impose it
as if it were a fact right we see this
all the time coming out of the critical
theory crowd where they take something
that they would like to be effect and
then they just assert that it is and
then the point is they go around
brutalizing people who say that isn't so
but you know it's awful yeah it's it's
awful so those who swear that men and
women are two different phenomena it's
like you know we're transphobes somehow
yep really
right that's what we are Oh fascinating
oh and if you think that there's some
relationship potentially between the you
know the level for virality lab in wuhan
and the fact that a corona virus that is
very similar to ones that they study
happens to have emerged in wuhan you
know what you are you're a conspiracy
theorist
this is authoritarian garbage right it's
not right anybody who needs to threaten
you in order to bully you into a fact
probably is not peddling a fact so
anyway and phobic conspiracy theorists a
transphobic can imagine boy my parents
would be so disappointed more from this
than we'll switch over I think oh this
is just a comment thank you guys
objective factual podcasts like this at
the antidote to the big media that has
caused our nation to become so polarized
much love thank you thank you thank also
let me see if I can find have you marked
got it all right so we're moving into
for the next twenty minutes or so the
next questions that came in in this hour
in the last podcast brett proposed a
change in presidential leadership as a
solution to our current madness I'd love
to hear more more details but more I'd
love to hear how there's thoughts on the
idea okay as far as more details you
deserve more details for those of you
who were not listening to the last live
stream let me say I proposed
thing and then at the most remarkable
moment during that proposal everything
went technologically nuts and I am
trying not to imagine that that was
something beyond a coincidence yeah it
was I was watching from the other room
yeah and it was it was truly some
stunning timing anyway but you should
say what it is for for people who don't
know it was a proposed here's the thing
I'm gonna do it right with the details
that didn't make it into that after the
technological collapse when we got back
online I was a little bit thrown by what
had happened it was I mean it was as
remarkable as it was for people watching
you have no idea how dramatic it was to
have everything go haywire at once here
so are you right right now or you okay
I'm gonna do it in an encapsulated thing
probably not live and I will upload it
and then you can see it so anyway
there's more to come but the basic thing
was there was a plan for bypassing the
major parties and their decrepit clown
candidates I particularly like the part
where he keeps calling them decrepit
clowns because that really is so
accurate I I think it's a great idea I
don't know how to get the attention of
the people whose attention we need and I
think it's necessary I don't I feel a
barrier that I have no idea how to get
out of the way I think but I do think
it's utterly necessary it felt necessary
four years ago it feels even more
necessary now yeah I think I think
history is doing us a favor right like I
mean history is doing us no favors in
the sense that bayonets are being issued
to American soldiers to go keep the
peace amongst American citizens but when
that kind of thing happens I think
people who have been telling themselves
some story about what it is we're gonna
do to get out of this problem are gonna
start to realize that they have been set
adrift in very dangerous circumstances
with completely inadequate tooling and
they're gonna have to start thinking
outside the box and listening to people
who've already started thinking outside
the box because otherwise we ain't gonna
make it
it's a tragedy podcast like this don't
have more viewers I hope people wake up
and realize how much better this content
is the mainstream media thank you I
disagree okay maybe I should rephrase
that I agree
bring your friends and you know spread
it around tell people yeah we would love
to have more viewers and we're very
grateful for the leadership we have it's
quite a number of people and it's it's
rewarding but it would be great it does
feel like it needs to jump into some
realms that people are just unaware of
it that's right would you both consider
running for Congress in an organized
effort with your fellow IDW friends to
form an IDW party alright you know very
well I can't run in an organized effort
just not going to you think yeah we've
we've we've talked about something like
this let's deal with the decrepit clown
problem first and then we'll talk about
it the other thing okay right so we'll
leave it there okay enough yeah I'm
gonna I'm just reading these in order so
I'm gonna read this next one do you find
it suspicious that George Floyd his
father the killer cop and Trayvon
Martin's father are all Freemasons and
what about George's chest tat I don't
because I didn't know that and I still
don't know what to make of it I still
don't know it yeah I don't have any of
that's true right nope yeah I don't know
I don't know to make it I mean that
actually is true I'm sorry to be making
light of it but just don't haven't had
time to independently assess and
honestly may well not get to it because
there are so many things drawing our
attention like what was it Banat
bayonets peanuts bayonets good okay I
must not see experts and leaders the way
you two do
I saw how she tried to explain it with
the quote but wasn't she describing
freedom itself what purpose does a
leader serve to you so I wonder which
quote you're talking about is the quote
from Trump or the quote from dust
have ski I don't get it
yeah but I will say the thing about
leadership is you know it's not we have
a a simulacrum of leadership and it has
confused us all because we have lost the
sense for what it's actually like to
have a leader and so therefore we don't
know what it makes us capable of and I
think probably people who have faced you
know if you've been in a foxhole then
you understand this intuitively if
you've been in a serious crisis you
understand it intuitively if you've
lived decades in America with the kind
of nebulous Evan flow politics that
really isn't about you it's kind of a
thin cover for a kind of corruption that
just you know has become so every day we
don't even see it then you don't get
what you're missing but you will if we
can figure out how to bootstrap
leadership back into existence do you
think people in America today are
working in the right direction to solve
the issue of police brutality and racial
profiling right now today no 10 years
ago I would have said I thought so I
thought we were we were moving in the
right direction five years ago not so
not so sure you know something is
shifting and it's becoming harder to do
the right thing I think I mean I just
think the problems with all of these
things there's a kind of reformer
mentality and the point is actually
we're so far off the mark that anything
that falls under the term reform isn't
going to be sufficient so what do you
mean by a reformer mentality that you
know there's all of this verbage about
here's the the plan what we're going to
do to address it and none of these plans
are ever very good and my point would be
actually a lot of
these things aren't a matter of tacking
some new thing that corrects the problem
on to the old thing that that's
emphasized it's more like what
assumption did we get wrong why does the
system work like this right and those
things more often are a matter of
thinking very carefully and discovering
the counterintuitive thing that you
overlook the first time rather than just
more architecture designed to address
the goddamn thing for once and for all
right so anyway my point would be reform
ISM to me is kind of uninteresting the
problem is the alternative to reform ISM
is awful often understood to be
something like revolution and that we
absolutely cannot afford revolution so
what I've been saying is we need
revolutionary change without revolution
we need something that is sort of
enlightened and brings us the the
upgrade without the violence that
accompanies it and this is readily
possible but it doesn't come from a sort
of piecemeal approach this is one of the
things that absolutely drove me crazy
about the primaries was this obsession
over policy details like these people
were supposed to be encyclopedic Lee
aware of all of the nuances of policy
and budget and all of this in order to
spell out exactly what they're going to
do as president even though that's not
what presidents do and you know it's
just it's a it's a it's a circus right
that's not how it goes what you really
want is somebody in the office who
gathers the right people and can have
the frank conversation where you can
actually navigate your way to what did
we miss
right yeah so before you said all of
that I was thinking that there are sort
of three categories of approach and the
one that you're calling the reformer
approach is add more stuff to the extent
architecture and see if that fixes the
problem and of course when it guarantees
is more bureaucracy more bureaucrats
more middlemen and middle management and
therefore will at the very least cause
bloat and then at the opposite end
excuse me
you have you have revolution
and this is you know this is what the
revolution is sometimes necessary all
right but the way that the anarchists as
you described in the last hour would
have us do it just even burn it all down
burn the whole thing down and let's hope
that we get a great-looking Phoenix out
of the ashes not gonna happen all right
and then there's this it's not
intermediate it's not an intermediate
thing but there is an approach that
involves looking at what we have looking
at this architecture and instead of
saying let's put some more stuff up here
or just let's destroy the whole thing
let's look at this architecture and look
at the decision trees and go okay well
that thing isn't working let's see if we
can undo that back to there oh it's
still not working back back back and
sometimes you're gonna have to take out
whole branches all right I'll call
branches of a tree or you know maybe
this is a systemic thing it's the forest
so sometimes you'll have to take out
whole trees but that doesn't mean burn
the whole damn forest down and it
doesn't mean add stuff on top of the
trees it means let's selectively prune
the things that we've got and create
better systems within a foundation that
you know are founded the foundation for
instance this country is solid it's
archaic in places it couldn't possibly
have predicted some of the things we're
dealing with now foundation our
foundation is solid yep it's it strikes
me that you know it's it's buckminster
fuller's ephemeralization yeah learning
to do more and more with less and less
until eventually you can do everything
with nothing and of course that's not to
be taken literally but that's the
process is you want a more and more
elegant system that is light
light-handed
that can do fantastic things and you
know we see elements of this right we
saw Elon Musk's SpaceX put astronauts
back into orbit under an American power
once again and was fantastic right we
see glimmers of this and then we see the
same people we see Elon also playing
with the solution to the traffic problem
is a system of underground tubes I mean
like you know he's got both impulses but
but anyway the point is people are
thinking and you know you gotta give you
a loan credit for having the vision to
imagine that civilization could look
like something different rather than
looking like an improved version of
saying yep
Heather what is your favorite joke of
brats Brett what is your favorite joke
of Brett's
I feel like this question came across
before we didn't get to it and instead
of thinking about it I haven't and I
think I don't I don't file things that
way I don't think you like my jokes
that's not true
it's actually that's really not true and
you know it I do but when I'm asked
almost any what's your favorite I freeze
and I can't I can't remember even what's
on the list I can't do it so it's not
it's not that I don't think you're funny
love it's a little like I don't think
you have this thing but um the most
mundane arithmetic becomes difficult at
the chalkboard for me I don't know why
that is yeah I don't have that problem
but but I see how it's the same thing
yeah there's it's just not the right
frame of mind I guess but yeah um okay
so I don't know what my favorite joke is
but I do have a joke I've been unable to
tell until now so it's not a it's not a
joke that you tell but it's one that I
resent that history denied me the
ability to deliver because I really
thought it was high quality there was a
point when John McCain a figure for whom
I had a lot of respect but I understand
there are some people who have you know
regard him as a war criminal oh no I
don't but anyway John McCain was dying
of a brain tumor and there was a
question about Trump attending his
memorial and John McCain had said that
he didn't want it and I very much felt
like tweeting at him I wouldn't pick a
fight with him at this point but it's
your funeral but I couldn't I mean it
would have been such bad taste and my
feeling is it's still too soon but you
asked the questions so this is on you
yeah no this is this is we can blame
Elliott yeah thanks Elliott
yeah now I should say I also the day
before your near-fatal boat accident huh
and we a lot because March 2016 we were
at this crater that we had hiked up
looking at this sort of active active
volcano and Isabella Isabella and there
was one of these smoke pots and I told
the students that they should go down
and it's new land that has emerged from
the magma they should go down and claim
it and it would be their fumarole which
I thought was a terrible joke but what
were they gonna do they were on the rim
of this crater they had nowhere to go
you've repeated it here yes well there
you go there it is you mentioned a
racial outreach session as a way to
lower the tensions but then mentioned
that it failed at Evergreen wouldn't it
fail anywhere because the premise is a
lie isn't this more about feral kids mmm
no you know I'm just gonna riff here for
a second the the fact about addiction
all right this is not a directly about
addiction but the fact about addiction
is that we've learned that actually
addiction whatever it is emerges in
light of boredom and nothing productive
to do and the people who have productive
things to do often will avail themselves
of those opportunities and I think
something similar is going on here there
were some baddies a couple in the
protests who at Evergreen yeah turn the
world upside down and I'm I have no
doubt that we are seeing the same thing
happen on the streets of major American
cities now where some people who
actually are just itching for a fight
because it's what they're good at are
creating these conditions but if you get
I mean for God's sake look at some of
these videos of the moments when the
protesters and the cops are trying to
figure out how to talk to each other
they're not even frankly the same
species right the weird thing that we
learned it occurred to me before the
Evergreen crisis that nobody in our
circle knows any police officers they
kind of don't circulate amongst us
right so it's not an easy thing to
figure out how they're just not at the
same barbecue so you don't have a
mechanism to learn how to talk to them
but the fact is if you if you cross that
bridge which I've done many times
intentionally there is a way and these
these protestors are discovering that
there are human beings on the other side
and the police are discovering that
these punk kids aren't necessarily all
punk kids and something wants to emerge
from that and it gets broken down for
the stupidest reason which is that any
one person who wants to sabotage it has
the ability to do so right you can't
have that but my point is are there
feral kids yeah there are a few of them
but I don't think they would be
dominating this in any way if we had a
coherent framework can you imagine that
list of people that we named if you
brought them together I mean frankly
Jonathan mcworter and and Glenn Lowry
together on the Glenn show like it's
non-stop fascinating these guys do not
agree with each other they don't come
from the same perspective they both
regard each other is highly decent and
the conversation reveals things
constantly now imagine that you take the
Glenn flow show and you add all of those
other people to that same stage and then
you just put good questions difficult
questions on the table people who care
about this would be fascinated by it and
they would be drawn in by the decency of
the people in the discussion I don't
think there's any way it fails I don't
and what failed at Evergreen was that
evergreen didn't have the decency or the
imagination to let it take place it's
not like we tried it and it didn't work
it's like they said now that's it I
guess I I read the question a little bit
differently a racial outreach session
it's not what you just described doesn't
sound to me like a racial outreach
session I think what this person is
asking is you know get get a bunch of
the protesters together to to engage
their their grievances perhaps with
policemen now this is something that for
instance I think that John Wood jr. has
been been working on with with better
angels and I think there's an I forget
now if he's now with a different
organization apologies John if you're
watching or if there's another
organization that's also do
similar work I'm sure there are that it
can be effective putting people who in
advance say absolutely I identify as
being someone who doesn't like those
sorts of people and allow them to simmer
down and just calm down and be together
listening to each other for a while and
people start to listen yep and I saw
Chloe Valerie one of our favorites
proposing something I think is quite
brilliant if she wants to hold basically
a boy I think it would be trivializing
him to call it a dance party but a dance
gathering in which the music is
carefully curated and she'd be such the
person to do that
um now I would say she gave an
abbreviation for the place she was
thinking of doing this and I couldn't
tell whether it was indoors or outdoors
Chloe it needs to be outdoors for viral
reasons but if you can do it outdoors
it's a great idea she's talking in New
York that's where she is yep and I think
you know it could be contagious in the
best sense but there's lots of energy
and creativity this again the irony is
this is the deepest bench we have we
have brilliant creative fascinating
highly decent people and we have a bunch
of them on this topic so what the hell
are we doing next question thank you for
doing this podcast would you two be
willing to take psychedelic mushrooms
with Jordan Peterson and Sam Harris for
the good of humanity yeah I'd be willing
to do that for the good of us yeah I
mean sure sure I have a feeling Sam and
I would end up yeah even a difficult
conversation I can I could have fun
talking to each other while you and Sam
did whatever you were it might become a
problem for each other but yeah I think
you might yeah yeah but anyway yeah it
sure you'd approach friends oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean you know all jokes
aside magic mushrooms are fun
but they're also an amazing tool for
mind broadening you know there's nothing
mystical about that and they basically
break normal thought patterns without so
thoroughly disrupting thinking that that
you can't be productive at it so anyway
yeah it's an important tool and you know
whatever the context was for the good of
humanity sure yeah are either of you
aware of Gilbert Lang's association
induction hypothesis what is our chance
to solving this pandemic if our
fundamental bilayer pump cell theory has
been experimentally disproven I think
that's two different questions but I
honestly don't know enough about either
of them to be totally sure yeah I mean
look I love a good deeply heterodox
hypothesis in biology and a lot of them
I mean most of them are wrong but the
frequency with which we see something
fundamental about what we believe
severely disrupted by what we then learn
is pretty high and so I don't know this
one particular but you're talking about
the bilayer pump cell theory now not the
Gilbert links Association induction
hypothesis or do you think it's the same
thing I wish I knew
yeah but you know I will say as we've
talked about before we have a problem
where there's certain things that you
can diagram very well and there are
certain things that are impossible to
diagram and so are you thinking like you
call up the image of the of the bilayer
pop at the cell membrane right everyone
can who's too spent any time with those
textbooks right I mean look even just
the definition of enzyme right yeah
right enzyme is a catalyst really I mean
yes technically sure but really no it's
a goddamn machine is what it is right
and you know it's like a factory but the
thing is those of us who grew up with
diagrams of an enzyme as a static entity
that you know took a triangle like
object and a square like object and
oriented them in such a way that they
clump together so the two sides fit
those of us who had that thing have a
kind of dim view of what an enzyme
really is and those of us who had the
animation in which you know the
replication complex is taking
units and you know like that thing we
have a much better sense of what it is
so you know there's a lot of places
where every biologist on earth is
synchronized into dim-witted thinking by
some bad drawing that caught on and the
sooner we free ourselves from those
things the better off we'll be there are
some really good animations to that you
have pointed me to and that you then
used when you were teaching intro bio
and I'm sure you know just even absent
everything else that you did just
handing the students those tools the
animation tools of the the tools of
molecular biology animated in the way
that we currently imagined it to be
operating is staggering I mean just even
the one we could probably show it at
some point but the one of the motor
protein marching the the
neurotransmitters down the axon of the
of the neuron right like yeah I mean a
you have to look it's adorable it's
amazing right it's just it's wonderful
and you know it's fits so well with the
mushroom question too because once
you've seen that that's what's going on
in your cells it just a whole different
universe right okay let's answer one
more question and then apologies as
always for not getting to all of your
questions so many of which are really
really high-quality Linda asks when
asked about meditation you responded
that you do not formally meditate
yourself but that you embark on doing
things that produce some analogous
effects could you and Heather elaborate
and what some of these things are may I
start by saying that I did I was lucky
enough to be invited as a senior in high
school to participate in a what was
called a Buddhist artists retreat and it
was sort of in 1987 that was led by tech
not Han who was then not very well known
but who was has now become fairly well
known as a as a Buddhist expat of Tibet
and I was there it was in it was an oh
hi in California at the Ojai Foundation
with a lot of Beat poets and various
other artists and
took not hon led us in three sitting and
one walking meditation everyday and
other times we you know we cooked and
kept the place clean and we wandered the
natural lands and we did whatever our
art was which for me was writing and
also I was doing some 2d and beginning
to do a little bit of ceramics and I
will say that while I did not keep up
the tradition of meditating much beyond
those two two and a half weeks or so
that that I was there with that amazing
group of people you know decades younger
than anyone else who was in attendance
that many pieces of it are exactly what
I go to write the the being in nature
being alone walking in solitude writing
finding finding the truth and beauty in
art and in creation and then also in
reference to the earlier questions there
is value in hallucinogens than
entheogens
as well yeah so I I play Mario Kart
actually I don't even know what Mario
Kart is but I know that there's
something called that so I don't take it
all back I don't find your jokes funny
fair enough
no you know actually this is an
interesting one I think I do a lot of
stuff that puts me in this frame of mind
it's not of one type the thing I miss
our old house the one we were forced to
move from when we came to Portland and
in general I'm very glad that we moved
to Portland but we had a second building
in which we had put in a basically a
tinkering space in a pottery studio and
tinkering for me is so it's not even
meditative it has that component but it
also just sort of trains the mind kind
of thing yeah and I miss it in our place
here well it has that potential we just
haven't gotten there yet and so I think
I'm suffering a little bit from its
absence and I'm probably getting
stupider which I would like to stop
doing soon there's also something that
both of us seek and have sought and have
inspired and our children is
well I have short-handed it to speed
that I just love the experience of
physical speed and we find it on bikes
and you this year just barely began to
introduce our children to it on skis and
then the lockdown happened and I think
you got out with him twice and I hadn't
yet gotten out with with you you know
it's mostly it's mostly bikes for us but
any ability to go really fast under your
own power is ecstatic in a way that
produces some of the same effects to use
some sort of Jamie wheels languaging
around seeking X tasks rather than
catharsis through you know some people
get it through meditation solitude quiet
depths and some people through you know
extreme sports and you know there's room
to be had for experiencing this getting
the kind of meditative effects in both
ways usually not simultaneously yeah I
would also add this woman I feel a
little weird about but I'm love the
bicycles I'm a huge fan and I like
skiing quite a bit and it was cool to
get back to it but there's this other
thing that we have started to do which
has a terrible name and it needs a
better one but electric unicycle an
electric unicycle is not honest in the
same way that a bicycle is you know I
bicycle you put in every bit of energy
to climb the hill and then you get the
reward going down the electric unicycle
is something you plug in it's got a
battery one wheel in a little case and
two pedals that you stand on but it's a
little bit like you know you don't put
in the energy to go sailing
all right the energy comes from the wind
but you take advantage of the energy and
it's very natural and in some ways as
synthetic is electric unicycle is it's
very quiet it's very natural and you can
whizz through the night if you want my
kids and I broke curfew the other night
and went out into Portland to see what
curfew looked like because I have an
authority problem I guess but so let me
say what's that suck you know we'll do
it another time yeah I will say that you
said this is I think this is the second
night of curfew
yeah okay so you said you know I think I
think I have to go out there I just
can't I've never been under curfew
before I can't I can't do it I gotta go
out there and I in a moment of just
brilliant parenting said well are you
gonna take the children now to be fair I
was under the explicit impression that
you were not going to take them down to
hell oh so was I what you then did right
at like 8:30 at night all right I think
we've confessed too much this is where
this is you know what this is I'm not
even sure if electric unicycles exist
what we're doing right instantly writing
cynic fiction on the spot and it's
marvelous I hope somebody invents this
thing eventually because it sounds like
it'd be great I'd love to try it really
all right awesome yeah dude I think I
think I'm recovered enough now for my
injuries not from an electric unicycle
but from it boat you know number years
ago yeah maybe that's where we should
stop for dinner
you've enjoyed our little experiment in
live fiction generation yeah actually
fiction generation fiction engaging with
fiction and and for me writing fiction
is also an answer to that question yeah
yeah absolutely all right well this has
been awesome please like subscribe and
yes if you think there are not enough
people watching this podcast you're
probably right so point them our
direction and we will do our best to
save provocative and facking things that
have somewhat regular or interval okay
be well stay safe
you